diamonds can cut glass just think about
that for a second where you got to put
that in
today we're going to laugh because
someone told me that snl has done
a lot of comedy sketches about direct to
consumer pharmaceutical advertising if
you don't know what dtcpa is
it's something that absolutely drives me
crazy because there's only two countries
in the world the us and new zealand that
allow direct to consumer pharmaceutical
advertising patients come in
asking requesting for these medications
at times when they don't need them and
sometimes they get quite upset because
they think they need them anyways let's
have a good laugh
and check out some of these sketches
when you get older your body produces a
lot less testosterone
and that affects everything that makes
you feel like a man
and you know she can tell but before you
face a full-on vitality crisis
you find a testosterone boosting
supplement on tv
but wait there's more we have a
testosterone supplement that will solve
everything that ails you i feel like
these commercials all take the same
exact route and snl is already nailing
it from the start
you know it's effective because it's in
a giant black canister
and endorsed by the strongest retired
athlete money can buy
and before you know it you're a brand
new
man you know what's funny they always do
that first of all there's a celebrity
endorser not so quite out of their prime
but still looking decent they're like
look they're taking it they're obviously
not and second they always show like the
better version of you
they take a person they make them look
tired they put makeup on them and then
they come in with oakley
shades and a tight t-shirt and it's like
your testosterone is back by the way too
much testosterone is a problem too
you did it you're a man again only one
problem
you've turned into a full psycho look at
yourself
man you're wearing skin tight muscle
shirts to work now
you're in your mid-50s with a jet black
goatee what's hilarious about this is
one of the biggest
issues with people taking bioidentical
hormone replacement testosterone
men who are over the age of 50 start
getting testosterone levels back
when they were 30. they all of a sudden
think that they can push harder step
aside string brain
and they end up tearing their biceps
their pecs because their muscles just
aren't quite ready to handle all that
weight all that extra testosterone has
made you an aggressive alpha nightmare
that's why you need beta force the only
supplement that can counteract and undo
all that other junk you've been taking
so you can be a regular middle-aged man
again the claims
the celebrity endorser feeling like a
macho man alpha male 1 and then
getting a little beta in there it's like
exactly everything you knew that was
wrong with these commercials
snl was like salt bae what if you could
have your period just
once a year my period once a year
once a year i'd like that new
annual extends the time between your
period by 11 months
each annual pack has 44 weeks of active
pills instead of the usual three
keeping you on a constant stream of
hormones so your time of the month can
be just once a year
and when it is time for your period hold
on to your
hat
i love tina fey
hey i do that with bear oh not bad
do not take if you are using maoi
inhibitors or if your occupation
requires you to operate heavy machinery
do not take any well if you plan to ever
become pregnant as it may turn your baby
into a fire monster in the days around
your period you may develop a leathery
tail and you all may cause you to
develop a second vagina
notify authorities in your town when
your period is imminent as they may want
to incarcerate you preemptively like a
wolfman
all pharma commercials have to give this
intense list of things that can go wrong
with you and it's always like
how in the world am i supposed to read
all that fine print and hear it and
comprehend what i'm saying
it literally says like are you tired are
you doing this but also you could turn
into a wolf man and a monster and a baby
and it is
it's like whoa what just happened for
years i suffered from vertigo
out of nowhere i'd feel dizzy
disoriented even nauseous
dramamine helped my flashes subside and
i hadn't had a flare-up
in years years years they're talking
about symptoms and it could be for any
illness ever so you listen you're like
oh i've had that just so that you relate
to it and you're like i want it
and i heard this new song that i loved i
loved
i looked to see who it was and that's
when the vertical hit
it was taylor swift taylor swift
taylor swift the whole room started
spinning
i felt nauseous i don't like taylor
swift i know i don't
yes you do you friggin love her hi
i'm neurologist dr david doctor over the
last
one month realizing you love taylor
swift has become the leading cause of
vertigo in adults
that's why now there's swift to me
that's a play on dramamine it's an
antihistamine medication that also helps
with motion sickness
i know people who've gotten dizzy off
listening to dealers
you know when i hit 50 my body went
through a big change and
not for the better severe erectile
dysfunction shattered my confidence set
me into a depression and
almost ruined my marriage and believe me
i tried everything
but then a friend told me about zentrax
so i tried it
and it worked zentrex is the strongest
male enhancement drug on the market
it increases blood flow boosts
testosterone and ends erectile
dysfunction
instantly so i asked my doctor about
xentrex
and he said zentrex what the hell is
zentrex and i said xentrax
it's the strongest male enhancement drug
in the world and it works and he said
he'd never heard of it
so i pulled up the zentrex website and
showed it to him he started laughing he
said are you insane man you can't put
that junk in your body it'll kill you
your heart will stop rhino horn ammonia
hydroxide that's what's in meth right
just write me a script or xentrex and
i'll be on my way my doctor said are you
deaf man
no i could lose my license you could die
i said yeah i think i still want it
though so give it to me write the
prescription
patients do come in asking for
pharmaceuticals by brand name because of
commercials like this
in fact one of the biggest problems is
doctors are afraid that if they don't
write the prescription the patient will
leave them a bad review
and hurt their business that's like the
huge problem with like medical
review websites guess what if a patient
writes a negative one a doctor can't
comment on it because of patient privacy
even if it's a complete lie
chantix presents real stories real
people
i'm kelly and i quit smoking with
chantix
kelly is a real chantix user she is not
an actress
well well actually um it's funny you say
that because you know i
i used to be an actress but she's not
anymore
she's just here to give a testimonial
all right all right
i really wonder every time i see a
pharma ad now are these
true actors and actresses or is this a
complete scam in front of my eyes and
they're saying it's a patient
testimonialism it's exactly this
chantix is actually a legit medication
we use in our everyday practice to help
people quit smoking when you come in i
say
are you smoking yes do you want to quit
let's talk about it and we can have that
discussion and chantix could be
something that we
may use it's not necessarily something
you have to take to quit smoking
i needed a birth control that could keep
up with my lifestyle
i wanted a birth control that takes a
limo not the city bus
because i could deal with cramps but not
something cramping my style
that's why we chose nuva bling that
would be
so painful and uncomfortable oh my god
there's actually a birth control known
as nuvaring but it's smooth
it inserts easily not rough diamond do
you know that diamonds
i think are the sharpest known element
diamonds can cut
glass just think about that for a second
where you got to put that in
newfoundlang is 70 effective at
preventing pregnancy
and 100 effective and getting depth swag
on
plus you can customize nuvo blink oh my
god
the insertion process hurts me and i'm
not even the one going to be using it
instead of throwing new bubbling away
each month you can reuse it as jewelry
did you get those earrings at tiffany's
close
i got them from my vagina
hold it is that what you're having for
breakfast
sure haven't you heard fiber is really
good for you
well there's fiber and then there's high
fiber
try this colon blood
sounds delicious does it sound delicious
because it sounds
absolutely disgusting colon blow and new
super colon blow warning may cause
abdominal distension
that much fiber is not good for you it
hurts my colon just thinking about it
i'm not even the one going to be using
it oh my god in general
fiber is good to eat and that's why we
like high fiber breakfast because it
controls the absorption of sugar in your
bloodstream it helps you have better
bowel movements and abdominal distension
sounds like a minor
issue compared to what colon blows
actually doing because abdominal
distension just means you feel a little
bit full and bloated
you have a bigger problem with colon
blow i have two videos for you to choose
from
click here if you want to see a
hilarious medical meme review or click
here if you want to see me laughing at
onion headlines that are obviously
medical related which one you're
clicking on
stay happy and healthy
[Music]